six jours et 10 heures la comète
découverte et si vous vous réveillez un
matin pour apprendre qu'une comète
menace de percuter la terre une comète
avec une puissance destructrice
suffisante pour anéantir une ville
entière science-fiction didot a
nécessairement une comète surgissant de
l'éclat aveuglant du soleil ne nous
laisserait que peu de temps pour réagir
et nous n'aurions nulle part où nous
abriter paradoxalement certains
chercheurs pensent que ce sont des
comètes qui il y a plusieurs milliards
d'années ont déposé les germes de la vie
sur notre planète
riches en composés organiques et en os
elle aurait apporté sur terre des
éléments fondamentaux créer à
l'intérieur des étoiles les comètes
serait donc à la fois créatrice est
destructrice et nous nous serions nous
mêmes en fait que de la poussière des
toiles
c'est un phénomène naturel d'une
violence inouïe et qui dépasse
l'imagination
l'impact d'une comète de taille
seulement moyenne aurait des
conséquences bien pires qu'une tornade
un tremblement de terre et une éruption
volcanique réunit le ciel s'obscurcit
ray des villes entières seraient rasées
et des forêts brûlées de la roche fondue
mitraille ray la terre et des pluies
acides retomberait sur toute la surface
du globe
le nombre de victimes serait
inimaginable
bien qu'il y ait peu de risque que cela
se produise de notre vivant les
scientifiques affirment que la terre se
trouve au beau milieu d'un stand de tir
cosmique et que tôt ou tard nous serons
frappé par un astéroïde pierreux ou une
comète de glace bien sur la terre est
bombardée quotidiennement par les objets
cosmiques
il y a environ une centaine de tonnes de
matières qui s'abat sur terre chaque
année mais c'est presque entièrement
sous forme de poussière des particules
plus grosses disons de la taille d'une
balle de tennis
ils entendent tous les jours de la
taille d'un ballon de basket tous les
jours aussi de la taille d'une maison
c'est assez rare une fois par an
peut-être en fait plus un objet est gros
plus la fréquence à laquelle la terre et
frappé dix minutes des objets de la
taille d'une petite ville ne percute la
terre car plusieurs millions d'années
d'intervalle heureusement il est donc
possible que la terre soit de nouveau
frappé mais il ya très peu de risques
qu'elles le soient par quelque chose qui
réussissent à traverser l'atmosphère
pour causer des dégâts importants
allez dire ça aux dinosaures eux dont on
pense qu'ils ont tous été exterminés par
l'impact d'une comète ou d'un petit
astéroïde
on a retrouvé des traces de cette
catastrophe
dans la péninsule du yucatan au mexique
enfouie sous mille mètres de sédiments
côtiers un cratère d'un diamètre de 200
km a été découvert il semble avoir été
causé par un corps de seulement 10
kilomètres de large
l'impact a projeté dans l'atmosphère une
immense gerbe de roche fondue qui est
ensuite retombé sur toute la surface
terrestre en une véritable pluie de feu
en fait en ce qui concerne l'impact qui
a causé l'extinction des dinosaures il
ya 65 millions d'années ce qui a eu les
plus grands conséquences et à tuer les
plantes et les animaux
ce sont les retombées de matière
incandescente qui ont mis le feu aux
forêts et aux prairies dans un incendie
à l'échelle planétaire
je pourrais presque sérieusement dire
que si on veut vraiment évaluer le temps
qu'il a fallu aux dinosaures pour
disparaître
la réponse est probablement environ 20
minutes le temps nécessaire pour que
cette onde de chaleur carbonise tous les
dinosaures qui vivaient sur la terre
ferme
ce nuage apocalyptique
sa compagne est pourtant une lueur
d'espoir l'extinction des dinosaures a
en effet ouvert la voie à de nouvelles
niches biologique
un autre groupe de créatures avait
désormais sa chance de petits animaux
jusque là passée inaperçue les
mammifères
une fois les dinosaures disparus il
commençait à se diversifier et au fil de
l'évolution une branche de mammifères
donna naissance à notre espèce en un
sens la comète tueuse qui a dévasté la
terre il ya 65 millions d'années a
indirectement permis l'apparition de la
vie humaine
les chercheurs se demandent si les
comètes n'ont pas joué ce double rôle à
la fois destructeur et créateurs à de
nombreuses reprises par le passé
il est presque certain qu en percutant
la terre des comètes et des astéroïdes
ont souvent perturbé le cours de
l'évolution
en fait lorsque les planètes étaient
très jeunes il y avait beaucoup plus de
commettre qu'aujourd'hui
où sont-elles donc tout parti plusieurs
milliers d'entre elles ont été balayés
en chemin par la terre comme de
vulgaires insectes sur un pare-brise
selon une remarquable théories formulées
il y a des dizaines d'années mais qui
commence seulement à s'imposer lors de
ces collisions les comètes aurait
apporté sur terre d'énormes quantités de
glace et de molécules à base de carbone
l'eau et le carbone sont essentiels pour
l'apparition d'organismes vivants et
certains astronomes sont convaincus que
les comètes ont joué le rôle de
coursiers de l'espace pour déposer les
germes de la vie sur une planète stérile
ironiquement les comètes ont aussi le
pouvoir de reprendre cette vie
région de la rivière tunguska en russie
dans la matinée du 30 juin 1908 une
petite comète ou un petit astéroïde a
effacé deux mille kilomètres carrés de
la forêt sibérienne
d'après des témoins oculaires une boule
de feu aussi brillante que le soleil a
traversé le ciel de la taille d'un
immeuble
le missile cosmique a dû se vaporiser
avant d'atteindre le sol car ni cratère
ni débris n'ont jamais été retrouvés
cependant la force de la détonation a
suffi pour briser des arbres comme s'il
s'était agi d'allumettes
des fenêtres ont tremblé à 800 km de là
et un bang supersonique s'est fait
entendre des milliers de kilomètres dans
toutes les directions
l'ondé de choc a été enregistrée sur les
sismographes du monde entier parcourant
deux fois la surface du globe
bien que beaucoup d'animaux sauvages et
été brûlés vifs les pertes en vies
humaines ont été minimes mais il s'en
est fallu de peu
si l'objet avait percuté la surface
terrestre quelques heures plus tard ils
auraient rayé de la carte non pas les
forêts de toungouska mais les immeubles
de saint pétersbourg
l'instinct de conservation est sans
doute l'une des meilleures raisons que
nous ayons de mieux connaître les
comètes
à la différence des orbites d'astéroïdes
qui sont assez similaires à celles des
planètes les orbites de comètes peuvent
couper la trajectoire de la terre sous
n'importe quel angle
les comètes donc foncé sur nous de
n'importe quelle direction
et comme cela a été le cas tunguska il
arrive qu elle se dissimule derrière
l'éclat du soleil
autrement dit elles peuvent nous prendre
à l'improviste les comètes c'est
vraiment la grande inconnue alors que
nous pouvons détecter les astéroïdes des
années avant l'impact prévu avec la
terre et tenter de faire quelque chose
les comètes nous prennent par surprise
elles peuvent nous prendre au dépourvu
par ce qu'elles viennent du système
solaire extérieur etc on les détecte
seulement quand elle commence à
valoriser leur glace c'est à dire
largement à l'intérieur de l'orbité de
jupiter donc alors qu'avec les
astéroïdes
on a des années pour se préparer à une
collision et qu'on peut les dévier
facilement avec une comète mon parlant
semaine l'homme a toujours eu peur des
comètes au ivème siècle avant
jésus-christ aristote a écrit qu'il
fallait les considérer comme des
messagers divins en général de très
mauvais augure
depuis les comètes ont été rendues
responsables de catastrophes diverses
telles que l'éruption du vésuve les
épidémies de peste et même les ravages
d'attila
les comètes se matérialisent
littéralement du jour au lendemain
une particularité qui déconcertait les
astronomes dans le temps aujourd'hui
leur comportement imprévisible
ravis les spécialistes comme david levy
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles j'aime
les comètes et que j'aime les traquer
c'est que les comètes font partie de
notre culture quasiment depuis l'aube de
la civilisation avant l'ère moderne
les comètes brillante était considérée
comme de mauvais présage
la raison en est qu'on ne s'attendait
pas à les voir
or les souverains prince roi et reine
était censée contrôler la terre la mer
et le ciel
donc si une comète brillante ou une
supernova apparaissait ça montrait qu'il
ne contrôlait pas le ciel
puisqu'il ne l'avait pas prêts dans
l'angleterre du moyen-âge la réputation
des comètes en tant que présage funeste
était bien établie aussi les rumeurs
allaient bon train lorsqu'au printemps
de l'année 1066 un objet fantomatique
apparue dans le ciel
le roi harold et guillaume le conquérant
était sur le point de s'affronter à la
bataille de hastings et tous deux
considèrent la comète comme un signe des
cieux le présage s'avérer fatal pour
harold puisqu'il perdit à la fois la
bataille est la vie
des années après la conquête normande
furent présentés sur la célèbre
tapisserie de bayeux le messager céleste
y figure en bonne place et une
inscription latine souligne son
caractère inquiétant
il regarde les toiles avec effroi
cette iec le plus tard l'objet fut nommé
comète de halley en l'honneur de
l'astronome anglais edmund aller dès
1705 celui-ci se basant sur la nouvelle
théorie de la gravitation d'isaac newton
avait en effet affirmé avec audace que
certaines comme est brillante observée
au cours des derniers siècles n'était en
fait qu'un seul et même objet un
visiteur cosmique qui un jour ferait son
retour
elles vont à l'est a fait un travail
mathématiques remarquable qui lui a
permis de démontrer qu'une seule et même
comète était apparu tout les 76 ans
environ il a littéralement dompter ses
chevaux sauvages qu'on appelle des
comètes et de ce fait nous les
comprenons bien mieux aujourd'hui
la boucle est bouclée en beauté
peut-être sont-elles vraiment aussi
inquiétante qu'on le pensait autrefois
car à chaque fois que nous voyons une
comète brillante dans le ciel il ya
toujours un risque qu'elle ou une de ses
soeurs entre en collision avec la terre
et apporte la famine la peste et tout ce
que les anciens greniers
les collisions avec une comète sont
extrêmement rares qui aurait pu penser
que nous aurions l'occasion de voir un
tel impact de notre vivant fort
heureusement c'était sur la planète d'à
côté l'observatoire du mont palomar en
californie du sud
pendant près de 30 ans ce site a abrité
le plus grand télescope au monde
le réflecteur elle avec un miroir de
plus de 5 mètres de diamètre mais juste
à côté se trouve un autre télescope plus
petit est bien moins célèbres et c'est
celui qu'on utilisait jean et caroline
schumaker et david levy pour chercher
des comètes au cours des années 90 ils
en ont trouvé un certain nombre mais en
mars 1993 leur neuvième découverte est
entré dans l'histoire dès le début la
comète shoemaker levy 9 ou s n 9 s'est
révélé extraordinaire des photographies
ont montré qu'elles étaient segmenté
comme des perles sur un fil et au mois
de mai de la même année
les scientifiques ont réalisé que ce
chapelet de com est allé percuter
jupiter dans toute l'histoire de notre
civilisation
on n'avait jamais vu d'impact d'une
comète sur une planète
et là on allait le voir ça allait se
passer
juste devant nos yeux cette journée du
22 mai 93 où la collision imminente est
annoncée à marquer le début de la
période la plus fascinante ma vie et
d'une des périodes les plus fascinantes
pour l'astronomie depuis l'invention du
télescope
malgré sa feinte spectaculaire shoemaker
levy 9 a eu des débuts modestes comme
tout les comètes
on peut se la représenter comme une
sorte à isbergues de l'espace en termes
de taille et de forme le noyau d'une
comète est comparable à un petit
astéroïde
à une différence près un astéroïde se
compose de roches et de métal quelle que
soit la température à laquelle on le
porte
il n'aura jamais de queue en revanche
les gaz et la glace contenu à
l'intérieur d'une comète sont si volatil
que de métamorphose unique se produit
lors de son voyage dans le système
solaire métamorphose déclenchée par la
chaleur lorsqu'elle pénètre à
l'intérieur de l'orbité de jupiter la
comète commence à ressentir la chaleur
du soleil
la boule de glace inerte minuscule corps
solide se métamorphose alors en un objet
spectrale et immensément grands en fait
la partie solide appelé noyau est
toujours là irrégulière ballottés et
enfoui dans une tempête de poussière et
de glace on pense que le noyau d'une
comète est un agglomérat poreux de blocs
de glace qui à en juger par l'exemple de
shoemaker levy 9 se brise facilement
la matière éjectée du noyau ce fragment
en grains microscopiques ces minuscules
particules soudain libérée après avoir
été conservé dans la glace pendant des
éternités seraient des vestiges à l'état
brut de la nébuleuse originel qui a
formé notre système solaire
et c'est dangereux par ici la montagne
de glace devient le théâtre de
spectaculaires jets d'eau lorsqu'elle se
rapproche du soleil de gigantesques
colonnes de gaz et d'eau jaillissant à
travers de profondes fissures qui
parsèment la surface l'objet libère
aussi des gaz délétère comme du monoxyde
de carbone et du cyanogen les comètes
sont également les rênes des régimes
amaigrissants pendant une brève période
à l'apogée de son activité en mars 1997
la comète elle baup évacuer 130 tonnes
d'eau et mille tonnes de poussière par
seconde
heureusement il s'agissait d'un spécimen
exceptionnellement grand avec un noyau
qui fait environ trois fois la taille de
l'everest
elle baup peut survivre à des centaines
de voyages autour du soleil au printemps
les geysers de la comète il ya coutach
et ont expulsé en spirale dans
l'atmosphère des gerbes de matières un
peu comme un arroseurs automatiques
le mélange de poussières et de gaz ainsi
rejeter à commencer par former une
traînée translucide de milliers de
kilomètres de diamètre puis ce nuage
s'est étirée en une peuvent apport aux
de dizaines de millions de kilomètres de
long quand on observe une comète dans le
ciel en fait c'est un concentré de vide
le vrai noyau de la comète est en
général trop petit trop éloigné pour
qu'on le voit directement ce que nous
pouvons distinguer c'est la matière
perdu par la comète
ces créatures éthérées ne survivent
jamais à des rencontres avec une planète
ainsi l'infortuné shoemaker levy 9
c'était un peu trop approché de jupiter
dans les années 70 sous l'action de la
force de marée jovienne sl 9 ceux des
formats et finit par éclater en une
vingtaine de fragments de plus d'un
kilomètre de diamètre et lorsqu'en
juillet 1994
ces fragments glace et ont percuté
jupiter les impacts ont dévasté des
zones incroyablement étendue de son
atmosphère
les astronomes en ont alors tiré des
conclusions peu réjouissantes quant à
l'avenir de notre propre planète
à mon avis la principale leçon à retenir
de l'impact des noyaux de shoemaker levy
9 sur jupiter
c'est les énormes nuages sombres qui se
sont formés ils ont atteint des diamètre
supérieur à celui de la terre en une
heure et demie et les plus grands de ces
nuages ont été créées par des corps qui
ne dépassait probablement pas 700 ou 800
mètres de diamètre
plus de 90 % de la lumière du soleil a
été absorbé par ses nuages qui par
ailleurs se sont maintenus très
longtemps sur l'immense surface de
jupiter ils se sont dispersés avec le
temps mais malgré cela ces nuages sont
restés sombre pendant des mois
donc la leçon à retenir c'est que si le
même genre de nuages se forment suite à
un impact de comètes dans l'atmosphère
terrestre
on peut s'attendre à ce que la terre
soit plongé dans l'obscurité pendant des
mois
une question qui mériterait d'être tirée
au clair tout les comètes les stèles des
marques
lorsqu elle s'écrase dans l'atmosphère
d'une planète est une comète causerait
tels les mêmes marques sur terre et sur
jupiter
difficile d'imaginer une réponse à ces
interrogations qui ne soit pas
traumatisante
quoi qu'il en soit la violente collision
mettant en cause jupiter nous a donné de
précieux éléments d'information en 1994
quand nous avons observé l'impact des
fragments de la comète shoemaker levy 9
sur julie
r nous avons vu le même type d'effets
environnementaux qui pourrait se
produire sur tech d'abord il ya eu
l'explosion elle-même et milliers voire
des millions de mégatonnes d'énergie
deuxièmement sur jupiter
nous avons vu des vagues se propager à
partir du point d'impact sur terre par
analogie si l'impact se produisait dans
l'océan
nous aurions des tsunami géant un gros
impact dans le pacifique pourrait former
des vagues de 30 mètres de haut qui ré
frappé toutes les côtes de l'océan
pacifique
troisièmement à chaque impact sur
jupiter
il y a eu un panache de matières
étonnamment bryant qui s'est élevé
au-dessus de la planète pour retomber à
la surface 15 ou 20 minutes plus tard ce
que les astronomes appellent l'événement
principal a été non pas l'explosion liés
à l'impact mais la retombée de ce
panache qui a provoqué un réchauffement
de l'atmosphère est à une onde de
radiations thermiques infrarouges sur
terre la même chose pourrait se produire
sur toute la planète
peut-être d'ailleurs c'est elle déjà
produite
l'extinction massive d'il ya 65 millions
d'années pourrait avoir été causé par
une pluie de roches fondues déclenchant
un incendie planétaire on peut aussi
imaginer un scénario moins violent dans
lequel un immense nuage de poussière
aurait empêché la photosynthèse causant
de ce fait une rupture de la chaîne
alimentaire
les scientifiques sont toujours à la
recherche d'un 10 pour découvrir ce qui
s'est réellement passé
en attendant ils continuent de se
demander si c'est une comète ou un
astéroïde qui a mis un terme à l'ère du
crétacé
la même question se pose d'ailleurs pour
l'objet qui a explosé au dessus de la
sibérie
il y a moins d'un siècle même si pour
les victimes cela ne fait pas grande
différence
bien que les comètes ne soient que des
boules de neige cosmique
elles peuvent pénétrer dans notre
atmosphère à plus de 200 milles
kilomètres heure soit plus de 100 fois
la vitesse du son
un corps aussi massifs lancés à une
telle vitesse représente une quantité
d'énergie impressionnante
cependant les comètes peuvent se révéler
plus créatrices que destructrice des
observations récentes ont montré
qu'elles sont très riches en molécules
organiques
l'énorme quantité de cette semence
céleste étant tombées sur terre dans un
passé reculer on peut se poser la
question suivante les comètes sont elles
à l'origine de la vie humaine
lorsque shoemaker levy 9 a percuté
jupiter cela a mis en lumière certes les
tendances destructrices des comètes mais
aussi leurs talents créatifs
les fragments sont tombés à une vitesse
d'environ 60 km seconde soit 200 voix la
vitesse de croisière d'un avion de ligne
et en analysant les sites d'impact les
astronomes ont vite découvert une
substance familière de l'eau cette eau
provenait tel de la comète pas vraiment
de jupiter pas vraiment des éléments qui
contenait de l'hydrogène et de l'oxygène
se sont combinés à cause de la force et
de la chaleur de l'impact pour donner de
l'eau caire histoires incroyables ont
regardé à travers les télescopes et la
nature nous montrait comment elle
fonctionne des processus similaires ont
peut être été déterminant pour le
développement de notre propre monde la
terre et toutes les autres planètes se
sont formées à partir d'un nuage
interstellaire de poussières et de gaz
il y a environ quatre milliards et demi
d'années elles se sont constituées par
un processus d'accrétion à mesure que
d'innombrables petits objets se
percutaient et s'agglomérer mais même
après sa formation
la terre a continué à être frappés par
des débris
il s'agissait essentiellement
d'astéroïdes et de comètes de la roche
de la glace provenant de la phase
principale de constitution des planètes
il est possible que ce bombardement et
dispersé les éléments organiques à leur
présence sur terre du moins une grande
partie de ceux ci notre planète était
probablement chaude stérile et dépourvus
d'eau durant les premières centaines de
millions d'années de son existence
enfin il y à 3 8 milliards d'années
environ
le gros du bombardement a pris fin mais
de nombreuses comme est frôlé toujours
la terre à l'époque par une nuit dégagée
normal là je cherchais des comètes et je
n'en ai pas trouvé une en cinq ans mais
à cette époque j'aurais vu passer une
comète toutes les 10 minutes le ciel en
aurait été rempli il aurait au moins
cinq ou six grosses comme est brillante
dans le ciel et des centaines visible au
télescope et un intervalle d'environ un
siècle elles se sentent écrasés l'une
après l'autre sur la terre en apportant
les éléments de la vie l'alphabet de
base de la vie c'est à chaud et l
carbone hydrogène oxygène et azote
ces quatre éléments qui sont restés
inactifs pendant d'innombrables millions
d'années ont finalement formé des
protéines ensuite de la rn et un jour
comme par magie
elles se sont transformées en adn et
avec l'adn la photocopieuse est prête il
y a de la vie qui peut se reproduire de
façon fiable et donc y rit à l'asie on
ignore la quantité de soupe organique
qui a ainsi été déposée il ya si
longtemps mais ce dont nous sommes
certains c'est que quatre milliards
d'années après que ces graines de vie
ont pris racine les humains ont pris
racine à leur tour à l'orée du nouveau
millénaire
l'une des découvertes les plus
fascinantes que nous a apporté la
science et que nous sommes bien les
enfants des comètes la collision de
chômer coeur levinoff a été un moment
décisif pour la compréhension de notre
héritage là nous sommes assis dans le
calme de ce magnifique désert avec des
arbres en fleurs et des formes de vie il
ya des cactus il y à nous il ya des rats
du désert et chevaux il ya des tas de
choses
le spectacle de la vie sur cette planète
a commencé grâce à des comètes qui ont
percuté la terre il ya des milliards
d'années
l'hypothèse des graines de vie issues
des comètes et controversé même parmi
les experts combien d'éléments
nécessaires à la vie était présent dès
la formation de la terre et combien ont
dû être livre en express nous l'ignorons
une grande partie de ce que nous
appelons l'espace vide est en réalité
rempli de nuages très diffus de
poussières et de gaz
or ce mélange nommé milieu
interstellaire s'est révélé être
composée d'éléments bien plus divers que
ce que l'on pensait il y encore quelques
décennies les astronomes estimé que ce
gaz était simplement de l'hydrogène et
de l'hélium et cette poussière quelque
chose comme de la poudre d'astéroïdes
pulvérisé puis nous avons appris qu'il y
avait des manifestations de chimie
organique dans les profondeurs glace et
de l'espace profond et ce fut un choc
nos observations nous ont permis
d'établir que les comètes porte en elle
les mêmes éléments bruts et la même
chimie organique que ceux détectés dans
le milieu interstellaire
ce sont donc bien elle qui ont dû
apporter ces substances potentiellement
fertile sur terre
certains chercheurs ont poussé le
raisonnement encore plus loin si la vie
a commencé à partir des molécules
complexes qui existent dans l'espace
alors il est possible qu'il y ait à
l'intérieur des comètes des virus ou
même des bactéries
si c'est le cas ces bactéries pourraient
sauter au passage sur la terre
chaque fois que notre planète passe à
travers la queue d'une comète
pas étonnant que ces spectres céleste
nous fascine tant au point que certains
leur font même la chasse aujourd'hui la
majorité des nouvelles comètes sont
découvertes par des télescopes robotisée
qui balaie le ciel sans intervention
humaine
mais quelques passionnés comme david
levy qui observent depuis son jardin
près de tout sonne dans l'arizona
continue à chercher des comètes de façon
traditionnelle pour le plaisir je me
prépare pour une soirée de chasse à la
comète
c'étaient les scop de 40 cm de diamètre
s'appelle miranda la dernière comme est
que j'ai découverte remonte à cinq ans à
chaque fois que j'en trouve une
je fait inscrire le nom de la comète
l'année et la date de la découverte sur
une petite plaque ici c'est un peu le
livre d'or du télescope le 15 avril 1994
c'est la dernière plaque et il ya une
place pour la prochaine que je trouve ça
peut-être jamais que je trouverai
peut-être ce soir je ne sais pas mais
j'aime faire ça
lorsqu'on voit les noms des dernières
comme est brillante découvert on
croirait lire la liste des passagers
d'un vol international
la comète iker sait qui a traversé le
ciel à l'automne 1965
la comète bennett était une flèche
d'argent par une nuit du printemps 1970
la comète ouest est apparu un matin de
1976 la comète de halley est restée
visible pendant des mois à partir de
l'automne 1985 la commedia coutach est
passé près de la terre en mars 1996 et
la comète elle baup a illuminé le ciel
nocturne l'année d'après les
scientifiques s'interrogent sur la
provenance de toutes ces comètes
il semble qu'elle se soit constitué en
deux groupes distincts il y a quatre
milliards d'années environ
dans un premier cas les forces
gravitationnelles de planètes gazeuses
géantes comme jupiter ont radicalement
modifié lors beat 2 millions de comètes
celles qui n'ont pas percuté deux
planètes ont été soit rejeter
complètement en dehors du système
planétaire soit propulsé très loin vers
les régions extérieures où elles ont élu
domicile dans un immense volume d'
espaces que nous appelons le nuage
d'oort le nuage d'oort sept ans très
loin direction des étoiles les plus
proches et la poussée gravitationnelle
d'une étoile voisine peut suffire à
déloger une comète du nuage et
l'envoyait lentement en direction du
soleil
des siècles plus tard la comète tourne
autour du soleil et repart vers la bim
en fait les petits corps de glace du
nuage d'oort ne viennent nous rendre
visite qu'une seule fois
elles ne reviendront pas avant des
dizaines de milliers d'années
la deuxième source de comètes serait la
ceinture de kuiper une zone en forme
d'anneau plat au delà de neptune
bien qu'elle soit plus proche de nous
que le nuage d'oort la ceinture de
kuyper est particulièrement intéressante
parce qu'elle abrite les vestiges les
mieux conservés de la formation
planétaire sans la présence de planètes
géantes dans la région pour les absorber
où les éjecter la plupart des objets
decuyper ont en effet subi aucune
perturbation depuis leur création
cependant il arrive que des objets de
kuyper tombe en direction du soleil est
tôt ou tard un corps brillant devient
visible à partir de la terre en général
une comète de la ceinture de kuiper
décrit une orbite extrêmement allongée
et revient dans notre voisinage tous les
deux ou trois cents ans
la comète de halley qui nous rend visite
assez régulièrement provient de la
ceinture de kuiper la comète elle baup
quant à elle vient du nuage d'oort et
nous ne la reverront pas avant très
longtemps
il doit y avoir des millions et des
millions de comètes dans le nuage d'oort
et quelques unes seulement ont
l'occasion de venir nous voir et il se
produit la même chose dans la ceinture
de kuiper une comète peut soudain être
perturbés et elle commence à se
rapprocher un peu et puis ces comètes
vont faire le tour du soleil et revenir
et refaire à nouveau un tour en
décrivant de grande et longue vie et
souvent elles vont rencontrer jupiter à
plusieurs reprises et leur période
changera elle passera à quelques
centaines d'années à 50
et puis à 5 ou 6 ans peut-être il ya une
comète ne mène que qui passent tous les
trois ou quatre ans donc elle est
presque toujours présent les chercheurs
attendent avec impatience l'air ou des
sondes spatiales pourront examiner un
grand nombre de comètes à courte période
de fêtes
un robot de la nasa a déjà entamé un
voyage qui devrait l'amener à moins de
150 km d'une comète
la mission a été baptisé stardust
poussière des toiles
les collages de la sonde stardust
il doit rapporter une capsule témoin des
éléments de la formation de notre
système solaire
le 7 février 1999 un robot nommé
stardust a quitté la rampe de lancement
de cap canaveral en floride
prévue pour durer sept ans la mission a
pour objectif un petit objet peu connu
une comète nommé vilte 2
les quatre propulseurs propergol solide
ont été largués la comète de wiltz
constitue un bon objet d'étude car elle
n'est éloignée que de 400 millions de
kilomètres environ
autant dire une faible distance à
l'échelle interplanétaire mais un autre
facteur la rend intéressante aux yeux
des scientifiques pendant plusieurs
milliards d'années la comète vilte un
objet de la ceinture de kuiper est en
effet resté gelé dans le système solaire
extérieur puis en 1974 elle s'est
rapprochée de jupiter et a reçu une
poussée gravitationnelle qui a réduit la
taille de son orbite
cette nouvelle trajectoire orbitale à
l'aillet mme desprez du soleil à moins
de 236 millions de kilomètres tous les
6,4 ans en 1978 la comète c'est
suffisamment approchés de la terre pour
que le suisse paul wille tu puisse la
repérer avec son télescope
après quelques calculs les astronomes
ont réalisé qu'ils avaient découvert une
boule de glace parfaitement conservés
qui ressentait la chaleur du soleil pour
la première fois des années plus tard
l'idée de la mission stardust a germé
dans l'esprit de scientifiques qui
voulaient observer une comète non pas
avec un télescope
mais avec un microscope
le projet consiste à envoyer une sonde
vers une comète afin d'y recueillir des
échantillons et de rapporter ces
éléments sur terre pour une analyse en
laboratoire la comète vilte a été choisi
pour cible
car canettes atkins le directeur de la
mission est conscient du fait que celle
ci représente une occasion
exceptionnelle d'examiner un témoin
cosmique qui dérivent dans le système
solaire depuis plus de quatre milliards
d'années
on est prêt pour le briefing de vol oui
dans 15 minutes
il sait également que le succès de la
mission dépend de la capacité de son
équipe à maintenir le contact avec la
sonde
là on est à plus de 30 millions de km de
la terre c'est ça imagine le temps pour
venir bosser
il dit que ça fait loin pour venir
travailler quelque part à 30 millions de
km de la terre et on va à combien
maintenant 110 mille kilomètres heure
oui je crois qu'on commence à ralentir
un peu
oui puisque on s'éloigne de la terre
c'est normal parfait
stardust est une grande première par
bien des aspects c'est la première
mission américaine vers une comète et
c'est la première fois depuis apollo que
la nasa va tenter de rapporter des
échantillons extraterrestre les
chercheurs sont impatients d'étudier la
poussière récemment libéré de la comète
les instruments scientifiques de la
mission stardust tiennent dans une sonde
de la taille d'un petit bureau
la sonde reçoit une grande partie de sa
poussée nom de coûteuses fusée mais
d'une trajectoire calculé avec soin pour
l'amener à frôler la terre
cette technique dite d'assistance
gravitationnelle permet de modifier la
direction et la vitesse de la sonde sans
utiliser de carburant après avoir
décollé au début de 1999
stardust est revenu vers la terre en
2001 pour recevoir la poussée
gravitationnelle qui l'a propulsé en
direction de la comète ayant énormément
accéléré
elle devrait couper leurs beats de vilte
de le 2 janvier 2004 avec un peu
d'avancé sur la comète
celle-ci doublera lors la sonde et
passera en son point le plus proche à
150km d'elle
au cours de ce bref rapprochement
stardust va tenter de recueillir des
particules de glace plus fine que le
diamètre d'un cheveu humain d'infiniment
petit grain de poussière des toiles
voulons autour de la sonde à une vitesse
de 22 mille kilomètres heure les
particules seront capturés par un
matériau amortisseurs nommé aérogel
évoquant une éponge
l'aérogel est un type spécial de vert
mousse si léger qu'il est à peine
visible
l'aérogel est un matériau extrêmement
bizarre c'est ce qui se rapproche le
plus du vivent en fait ces composés à
99,9 pour cent de rien le reste c'est du
gel de silice
on dirait de la fumée solide on peut
voir à travers et ce qui est fantastique
c'est que sa densité est si faible que
lorsque les particules arrivent à une
vitesse de 6 km seconde elle s'enfonce
dans la et roger ailes sans se
désagréger lorsqu'une particules percute
l'aérogel elle creuse un long tunnel
conique appelé carottes
lorsque la mission sera terminée les
scientifiques pourront récolter un
millier ou plus de particules à
l'extrémité des carottes pour les
analyser recueillant ainsi moins d'un
centième de grammes de poussières
cométaires
pourquoi autant d'agitation pour une
simple pincettes poussière les
astronomes pensent depuis longtemps que
les comètes contiennent des blocs de
construction élémentaire restant de la
formation du système solaire
le projet stardust pourra donc nous
renseigner sur cette matière exotiques
qui a donné naissance aux planètes aux
lunes et à la vie dans notre région du
système solaire dans des endroits comme
la terre on sait que le matériau a été
grandement altérée
il a été chauffée compressé cetera si on
prend un échantillon de terre sur notre
planète
on ignore de quelle manière il est
apparenté au matériau d'origine dans la
nébuleuse solaire
en revanche les comètes ont été
conservés à l'état de glace pendant la
plus grande partie de l'existence du
système solaire donc quand une comète
s'approche du soleil et qu'elle perde la
matière en fait nous voyons des
échantillons du matériau qui existait
dans la nébuleuse solaire
il y a quatre milliards et demi d'années
et n'oublions pas les photos s'il n'y a
pas trop de débris
l'appareil photo numérique compact de
stardust prendra une image du noyau de
la comète vilte au moment où elle sera
la plus proche pour l'instant les
scientifiques ne dispose que d'une seule
séquence de photos d'un noyau de comètes
qui date de 1986 lorsque la sonde
européenne giotto a immortalisé la
comète de halley si cette image
historique semble un peu flou ce n'est
guère surprenant quand on sait que la
photo a été prise au milieu d'une sorte
de tempêtes de poussière on peut y voir
un noyau en forme de cacahuète bien plus
gros que celui d'une comète moyenne 16
km de diamètre environ
et à la surprise générale cette boule de
glace s'est révélé avoir une surface
thouars comme du charbon
stardust va tenter de prendre des photos
bien plus détaillé mais ce ne sera pas
une tâche facile à 280 millions de km du
soleil la lumière est trois fois plus
faible que sur terre et malgré la
présence de gaz lumineux qui forment la
queue de la comète
le noyau lui-même à les propriétés
réfléchissantes de la suite
le 31 décembre 2003 les contrôleurs de
la mission stardust attendront sans
doute pour fêter le nouvel an que le
rendez vous spatial est eu lieu 48
heures plus tard messi stardust réussie
l'équipe scientifique communiquera des
images de la comète vilte où l'on pourra
distinguer des structures de surface
plus petite qu'une maison et la tension
sera encore plus grande pour le retour
de la sombre le 15 janvier 2006
stardust repassera une dernière fois
près de la terre et éjectera une capsule
de la taille d'une valise contenant
l'aérogel et son chargement au centre de
contrôle l'anxiété sera à son comble
lorsque la capsule entamera sa violente
descend dans l'atmosphère terrestre à
près de 45 mille kilomètres heure soit
plus d'une fois et demie la vitesse
d'une navette spatiale revenant sur
terre un peu plus vite et toute la
poussière de comètes partirait en fumée
le résultat sera d'ailleurs le même si
le parachute ne s'ouvre pas mais si tout
se passe bien
la capsule atterrira doucement dans la
neige sur une base d'entraînement de
l'aviation américaine dans l'utah
enfin les scientifiques auront une
pincée de authentique poussières
cométaires a analysé elle sera étudiée à
l'aide d'instruments 100 fois plus lourd
et plus imposant que la sonde stardust
il était impossible de faire rentrer de
telles machines dans une fusée et c'est
pourquoi la mission a pris le
contre-pied de la démarche classique qui
consiste à étudier la cible entièrement
dans l'espace pour une mission comme
starbucks en inversant le mode d'aproz
on peut aller chercher les échantillons
et les rapporter sur terre
et là les scientifiques du monde entier
donc une communauté de chercheurs très
importantes se serviront des meilleurs
instruments de laboratoire partout dans
le monde dans des universités ou des
institutions on pourra utiliser des
appareils très sophistiqués et très
lourd comme des microscopes
électroniques entre autres pour observer
ces particules de très près d'où
proviennent les blocs de construction
qui ont servi à fabriquer les planètes
dans quel ni cosmique les systèmes
solaires n'est style
la réponse se trouve peut être dans un
endroit lointain et magnifique appelé la
nébuleuse de l'aigle stardust n'est
qu'un début
les agences spatiales américaines et
européennes ont prévu au moins une
douzaine de missions vers des astéroïdes
et des comètes dont certaines sont déjà
en cours
par exemple la sonde comète nucléus tour
ou contours sera lancée en juillet 2002
ce minuscule vaisseau frôlera les noyaux
de plusieurs comètes à partir de la fin
de l'année 2003 lorsqu'il passera à
moins de 100 km de la comète m que haine
que vous souvenez c'est la comète qui à
la période orbitale à plus courte
seulement 3,3 ans elle a été réchauffé
par le soleil à plusieurs reprises les
astronomes auront donc l'occasion
d'étudier des glaces cométaire ayant
subi des transformations importantes
en 2005 dans le cadre d'une mission
nommée deep impact
la nasa enverra un projectile de cuivre
percuté la surface de la comète tempel 1
à 30000 km heure creusant un cratère de
plusieurs dizaines de mètres de diamètre
lors de la pulvérisation du projectile
des tonnes de gaz et de poussières
cométaires seront éjectés dans l'espace
des instruments analyseront cette
matière et des caméras enverront des
images en direct de l'événement vers la
terre l' agence spatiale européenne
prépare un ambitieux projet du nom de
rosetta consistant à envoyer une sonde
en orbite autour de la comète virtanen
en avril 2012
un an plus tard un module tripode
tentera de se poser à la surface pour
effectué des carottages en septembre
rosetta sera toujours en orbite autour
de son hôte lorsque la comète atteindre
à l'apogée de son activité sous l'effet
du soleil
je pense que la raison de toutes ces
missions vers des comètes mission de
survol de rendez vous et de collecte des
échantillons
c'est qu'on a compris que si on veut
étudier le mélange à partir duquel le
système solaire s'est formée alors les
comètes et les astéroïdes représentent
les corps les plus primitifs et les
moins transformés de ce processus de
formation
il ya aussi une conscience accrue du
fait que ces choses nous tombe
effectivement dessus de temps à autre
donc il est de notre intérêt de les
surveiller et bien sûr la troisième
explication c'est qu'au siècle prochain
quand nous commencerons à coloniser le
système solaire intérieur nous aurons
besoin de métaux pour nos structures
spatiales
or certains astéroïdes sont en fer
massif il nous faudra de l'eau pour
survivre l'eau est nécessaire à la vie
et il nous faudra de l'eau pour la
décomposer en oxygène et en hydrogène
pour le carburant des fusées or les
comètes sont à moitié composée d'eau en
plus elles sont amusantes facile à
atteindre
elles ont tout pour elle
la matière dont les étoiles et les
planètes sont composées et dispersées
dans toute la galaxie dans les
profondeurs de l'espace d'énormes nuages
de poussières et de gaz donne naissance
à des systèmes solaires entier dans
l'immense nébuleuse de l'aigle à six
mille années lumière de la terre
le télescope spatial hubble a repéré des
systèmes planétaires en formation
des comètes in est également et
peut-être apporteront elles un jour
l'élixir de la vie à une planète
nouvellement apparus
il est possible que dans la voie lactée
ce soit les comètes qui est permis de
produire sinon la vie du moins les
conditions favorables à son apparition
or si ces comètes sont à l'origine de la
vie sur terre
peut-être le sont elles aussi ailleurs
au minimum les comètes symbolisent nos
liens avec un univers qui semble
pourtant lointain et inaccessible
présage funeste où merveilles de la
nature les comètes ont une beauté
inquiétante qui captive l'imagination
des hommes depuis des milliers d'années
et tous les dix ans environ de nouvelles
comètes brillante viendront sans doute
raviver cette fascination
nous ne savons pas exactement quand ni à
quelle distance elles passeront mais il
nous faudra saisir l'opportunité qu'elle
nous offre d'apprendre où nous pourrions
le payer très cher après tout la peur de
l'inconnu et parfois justifiées les
dinosaures en savent quelque chose